الازمه المصرفيه لم تنتهي بعد يقول هنا
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن الذي تتراجع
شعبيته الى ادنى مستوى بسبب هذه الازمه
فوفقا لاخر استطلاع للراي نشرته شبكه
فوكس نيوز الامريكيه ارقام استطلاع اظهرت
تراجع نسبه تاييد بايدن في مارس الى 38
بالمئه بعدما كانت 43% في فبراير الماضي
بايدن اوضح انه يفعل كل ما هو ممكن
لمعالجه الازمه المصرفيه داعيا الكونجرس
الى فرض عقوبات اكثر صرامه على كبار
المسؤولين التنفيذيين في البنوك الذين
يساهمون بسوء ادارتهم في فشل مؤسساتهم في
اشارات طبعا الى الفوضى التي خلفها انهيار
بنكي سيليكون فالي وسجنتشر مؤخرا ما ادى
طبعا الى تراجع كبير في ثقه المستثمرين في
القطاع المصرفي الذي هوت اسهمه وثارت
مخاوف من حدوث ازمه شامله كما اسهمت
مشاهدينا ايضا صفقه انقاذ بنك
الاسبوع الماضي واعلان بنك فرصه انه
سيستحوذ على ودائع وقروض بنك سيليكون فالي
لاستعاده بعض الهدوء للاسواق لكن
المستثمرين طبعا مازالوا قلقين من المزيد
من المشكلات الكامنه في النظام المالي
العالمي وفي وقت سابق اتهم البنك المركزي
الامريكي امام لجنه في مجلس الشيوخ ان بنك
سيليكون فالي اقدم على اجراءات بالغه
السوء فيما يتعلق باداره المخاطر قبل
انهياره
[موسيقى]